[Musique]
certains vont encore partir à la chasse
aux oeufs ce week end d'autres vont
pouvoir découvrir ce qui a un citoyen et
même un écocitoyen mélanie le
rendez-vous des juniors de cette semaine
se passe à magny les hameaux
et oui en une journée les enfants vont
pouvoir être un enquêteur sur une scène
de crime dessiner autour des droits des
enfants à prendre des premiers secours
savez ces premiers gestes qu'on peut
faire quand une personne un accident ou
se blessent
cette journée éco citoyenne c'est le
temps fort la conclusion de la semaine
de la citoyenneté qu'a eu lieu dans les
écoles et les centres de loisirs de la
ville en novembre 2017 mais aussi tout
au long de l'année
c'est important de travailler là-dessus
avec les enfants parce que c'est tout
petit qu'ils apprennent hisser les
citoyens de demain donc il faut les
faire travailler sur le thème de la
citoyenneté c'est la finalité de tout ce
travail qui a eu depuis pratiquement la
rentrée des classes
depuis le début de l'année scolaire en
fait et plusieurs manifestations sont
prévues avec notamment la gendarmerie de
magny les hameaux la sécurité routière
les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers donc
difficile un petit petit et tout le
monde et il y a une particularité aussi
cette année
et oui les manies quoi ne seront pas
seulement des citoyens ils seront des
éco citoyens
plusieurs ateliers ateliers ludiques
sont proposées on pourra recharger son
téléphone portable en pédalant ils vont
être aussi sensibiliser à leurs droits
et leurs devoirs et ils vont pouvoir
partager un pique nique écocitoyen
écouter les habitants amènent leur
dessert la ville fournit tout en fallait
lent très lent fin tous les plats le
matériel est il le but c'est qu'il y ait
zéro déchet et donc pas lambada
d'emballage pas de plats pas de
vaisselle jetable de quoi laisser
l'estaminet café aussi propre lorsqu'on
est arrivé
la journée écocitoyenne débute à 10
heures à 10 heures du côté du gymnase
auguste delaune et tout le programme est
à retrouver sur le site internet de la
commune qu'est nichée pas si vous voyez
une activité qui vous intéresse et on
m'a même sensible à la démarche du 2 0
des chaires le pique nique me tenterait
bien je pense
merci en tout cas mais la ligne vous en
reparler de cette journée éco citoyenne
on le rappelle se déroule ce samedi 7
avril